la france n'a pas mis le paquet sur
quelque chose qu'elle un consensus
général s'est opérée dans toutes les
familles politiques dans toutes les facs
ont espéré dans toutes les familles de
pensée à savoir mettre l'accent
souhaitant plus
moi je dis simplement essayons de tout
faire et les députés en particulier
parce que je vois que les députés qu'il
s'agit pas raison qu'à faire voter et il
a comme voté à une majorité ne touraine
a rassemblé autour de lui une majorité
d'étudiants qui met le paquet sur ce qui
nous rassemble tous à savoir cela et
puis après on verra
voilà moi je je je suis contre la
légalisation du cannabis assez claires
et des difficultés à suivre mais je
trouve qu'il ne faudrait pas dans le
débat qu'on puisse présenter l'aide
active à mourir ou l'euthanasie comme
une solution soit aux difficultés
actuelles de la mort soit à l'absence
d'ambition politique relative aux swaps
à nu la clé sanitaire la crise de la
corrida prouver qu'on m'aurait mal en
france on ne sait on a laissé mourir des
personnes on a dû crier des personnes on
le sait c'est pas mal de le dire c'est
la vérité c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé
évidemment le débat sur le mieux mourir
en france est un débat qui est
d'actualité mais c'est un débat qui a
été toujours confisqué ça a toujours été
un peu d'un débat d'actualité bon là
confié souvent aux mauvaises personnes
alors aujourd'hui effectivement
l'assemblée nationale a changé
effectivement on peut espérer qu'il y
ait un combat trans partisan sur la
question de la fin de vie maintenant
faut tout le monde arrive à se mettre
d'accord autour de la table pour porter
ce sujet qui pour moi doit être et
l'accès universel aux soins palliatifs
et une légalisation de l'aide active à
mourir c'est à dire une légalisation de
l'euthanasie et du suicide assisté pour
laisser ouvert le champ des possibles à
chacun et surtout qu'on respecte le
libre choix de tous nos concitoyens
quand on est comme cela bien portant et
qu'on veut effectivement d'une façon ou
d'une autre
considéré qu' au moment de la mort on va
souffrir ça va être difficile
on voudrait avoir un choix qui n'est pas
celui dû laisser mourir mais dû faire
mourir on est d'accord en théorie écrit
en pratique quand on est confronté dans
les une sympathie on ne l'est plus et
donc il faut respecter cette
indétermination a priori et cette
difficulté de vivre ces moments là et
donc c'est pour ça je suis contre mais
je les ai toujours dit légalisation de
l'euthanasie mais je ne suis pas contre
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire
au cas le cas quand effectivement les
questions sont complètement difficile
comme ça se passe aujourd'hui d' essayer
d'aménager un moment un temps à l'espace
et puis quelque chose qui permettrait
peut-être d'accélérer un tout petit peu
le mouvement dans la concertation
considérant effectivement que la fin est
proche et que les souffrances sont
réfractaires et qu'effectivement il n'y
a plus rien d'autre à faire donc voyez
je suis je vais le dire un peu je pense
que monsieur univers sont amusés mais je
suis pour l'hypocrisie je pense que
l'hypocrisie fait partie des conditions
humaines et que donc il faut accepter
des choses au cas le cas dans des
situations sans pour autant en passer
par le la validation de la loi
vous savez d'abord c'est un sujet tabou
en france beaucoup d'autres sujets mais
c'est un sujet tabou pour autant
effectivement tous les sondages envie de
89 à 96% des français qui sont
favorables à une évolution de la loi la
loi actuelle parce que la loi actuelle
et c'est effectivement ce qui peut nous
opposer avec monsieur les gays pour moi
n'est pas absolument suffisante et moi
je crois que le législateur est prêt
pour faire évoluer cette loi les lois
sont prêtes à être évalués et à évoluer
sur tout mais il faut pouvoir poser le
débat sur la table y est allé sans tabou
et avec l'esprit que ouvrir à nouveau
droit ce n'est pas créer une obligation
mais c'est la seule condition pour que
de mal le citoyen se disent qu
effectivement il maîtrise son corps et
imams ormes appartient ni plus ni moins
aujourd'hui la mort c'est un sujet tabou
mais
les français sont prêts à dire voilà ce
que je ne souhaite pas il ya quelque
chose qui est imposé à un moment donné
et qui fait que d'une certaine façon la
liberté dont parle russe de nice n'est
pas une liberté qui est au jour
d'aujourd'hui dans le cas dans la halle
aux eti accepté partir du moment où le
mur saute ou l'euthanasie est acceptée
malheureusement tous les cadres que l'on
met pour protéger ce qui est le cas au
début
l'euthanasie des dérives possibles sont
progressivement donc ces trois raisons
la la confusion du médecin de la
question de la persuasion et un risque
d'abus de faiblesse et 3a les dérives du
cadre font que me semble-t-il
il importe d'en rester à cette liberté
là qui est celle d'aujourd'hui
la loi léonetti et de ne pas passer à la
liberté qui sera effectivement celle qui
inclurait l'euthanasie à l'intérieur des
soins possibles moi je ne vois pas de
dérive et je ne comprendrais pas que le
législateur par crainte de dérives ne
fasse pas voter une loi justement si on
fait voter une loi c'est une loi qui
encadre par contre s'il ya des dérives
et bien ça serait que devant la justice
donc je ne dis pas qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir de dérives dans une loi qui existe
mais ça serait même du point de vue de
la justice
aujourd'hui il faut pas se mentir il ya
des jeux d'asie qui existent en france
on évalue à 4500 5000 l'euthanasie qui
se fasse on peut dire le médecin
compatissant on peut dire le médecin et
aimant mais aujourd'hui des études qui
sont de l'ined qui n'est pas d'importer
institut ne prouve que il y à des
euthanasies qui se fasse sur des
personnes sur qui on n'a absolument rien
demandé à l'association pour le droit de
mourir dans la dignité
c'est parce qu'on souhaite on veut que
chacun puisse est maître de son choix de
sa mort et on ne peut pas accepter qu'on
ne t'a nazis les personnes sont laura
corps ou sans l'accord de la personne de
confiance